how much I imparted to them I think they
impart things to me here please I think
that luckily there are really great
beings still coming to this planet who
are beings who are I think in each
generation there's kind of room for
beings who are better than the old
beings and I think the old beings
actually some of them unfortunately you
get all negative about that and they
like into how they must be something
wrong with the new beings and they don't
really care about them actually if you
look at there's so many countries that
are having authority crisis's now where
they are people are the old-timers the
people with power are freaking out and
trying to turn the clock back and like
get back into some sort of medieval
situation in America that's you know the
huge fundamentalist movement is doing
that because I think they're afraid of
their own children actually they're
afraid of their women and they're afraid
of their children and they're unwilling
to admit that their children might be
more visionary better more developed
more far out than they are and so
they're going citing some old ancient
rule or law some dogmas from some old
suppose that sacred text written down by
some funky old fogies long time ago and
they're like trying to crush down you
know like Iran I think something like
60% of the population is under 25 in
Iraq we killed so many now but a lot of
people they were young you know the
older people are less and so the whole
world is kind of like that the young
there's this huge amount of youth in the
world and I think they're all smarter
than the older people actually and
they're brought up in a better and more
open way even in the craziness of it all
you know and and so the older ones are
still clinging to like we're still
Knights in Armour or we're World War two
warriors or weird we are powerful people
or something like that rather than
recognizing the sort of common humanity
of themselves and all the other people
think the young people are moving
against that in a certain way younger
people and I think we haven't we have to
you know we have to hope that they will
move more strongly it's so soon enough
to reverse the destruction that is
taking place
how do I look at I'm a big fan of them I
think she's wonderful I think that the
industry she's in doesn't take proper
advantage of her they don't really
realize how remarkable she is she's had
a few things done for her that fit her
in a certain way and they've been
tremendous successes but often she's
asked to squeeze into something that is
really less than her subtlety and her
intelligence and her brilliance I
remember and I think an Anthony Lane
review of Henry in June long back where
he said that she was like Dietrich that
when she appeared on the screen she
brought a jolt to the screen as a
wonderful term like that and that is I
think the case that comes from her own
we call it karma her evolutionary
background she's an amazing being in her
own right and it's just she you know
she's often putting the roles that are
really not up to her
and she needs more thing specially
designed for her you know Quentin did a
couple of good things but the other
people should really do that and realize
that but in a way she's not the
conventional sort of you know Miss
American be good or something like that
she's complicated
no like Garbo was or something she's
like like Carmelo was never used
properly until some director fell in
love with her and started making movies
especially for her and there are these
are extraordinary beings who are
vehicles like that they don't have a
special conveyor a special sensibility
to the world I think just by being this
to themselves relevant to what they what
they do and then they use all the great
dramatic model you know the great
dramatic vehicles to do that and new
ones that can be created so anyway I'm a
frustrated screenwriter myself I'd like
to write things for her but then she
just Oh daddy come on you're not in the
business and brushes me off